y
qué
[Música]
así despegó en la madrugada de este
viernes en la tercera misión del space
ex tripulante de la estación espacial
internacional desde territorio
estadounidense el equipo de la misión
crudo se está compuesto por dos
astronautas de la nasa un japonés de la
agencia espacial de jaxa y el francés
toma pesca de la agencia espacial
europea tenemos reporte desde cabo
cañaveral
en el primer día de la cumbre virtual
para mitigar la crisis climática el
presidente joe biden se comprometió a
reducir las emisiones de carbono en un
50% para el año 2030 china anunció una
reducción gradual del consumo de carbón
y en américa latina' el presidente de
brasilia yr bolsonaro prometió
neutralidad de carbono hasta 2050
colombia superó el umbral de los 70 mil
muertos por joven 19 tras registrar 430
fallecidos la cifra más alta de decesos
en 24 horas desde que llegó el virus al
país sudamericano mientras avanza
lentamente el proceso de vacunación y
regresan las estrictas medidas de
confinamiento que habían sido relajadas
rey
s
[Música]
muy buenos días soy re blanco un gusto
como siempre saludarlos en esta
oportunidad así comenzamos nuestro
informativo con el lanzamiento exitoso
del del cohete falcon nine de space ex
que despegó desde la plataforma 39a del
centro espacial kennedy en cabo
cañaveral en la costa este del estado de
la florida en eeuu el equipo de la
llamada misión crudos está compuesto por
los astronautas de la nasa james gym
work y megan mcarthur así como el
japonés akihiko hoshide de la agencia
espacial jaxa y el francés toma pesqué
de la agencia espacial europea se trata
de la primera vez en más de 20 años que
astronautas de las tres agencias
espaciales realizan juntos una misión a
la estación espacial internacional la
misión va a revelar a la que uno de
spacex que partió de cabo cañaveral en
noviembre pasado para conocer más
detalles acerca de este lanzamiento y el
contexto que hay detrás de toda esta
hazaña tenemos a nuestras enviadas
especiales
truyenque desde el lugar del lanzamiento
en cabo cañaveral y también a natalia
ruiz quien se encuentra en toulouse
francia y nos reporta desde el centro de
astronomía científica comienza saludando
aclara truyenque y le pregunto clara
cómo se vivió el lanzamiento y qué
detalles se conocen detrás de todo este
despliegue
saludos para todos desde cabo cañaveral
como pueden ver con esta vista y a tan
sólo 24 kilómetros estoy en este momento
de donde se ha producido el despegue
lanzamiento de ese cohete hace unos
minutos como pueden ver el cielos
parcialmente nublados y es que se
seguían muy de cerca las condiciones del
tiempo era de hecho la clave para
decidir si sería de nuevo pospuesto o no
este lanzamiento porque como saben ya
fue pospuesto una vez y de hecho había
una fecha tentativa para el lunes he
podido hablar con expertos cercanos a
este proyecto y me han contado que los
cuatro astronautas tres hombres y una
mujer han estado entrenando solo para
este proyecto durante los últimos tres
años han sido cientos de horas también
ellos vienen con cientos de horas de
experiencia en vuelo en tripulación y
han estado en el espacio previamente les
cuento la tripulación formada como les
decía por tres hombres y una mujer
tienen mucha experiencia por ejemplo un
dato muy curioso que he recabado es que
el astronauta megan mcarthur se sentó en
el día de hoy
imagino que emocionaban porque se sentó
en el mismo asiento
su esposo también astronauta viajó a la
estación internacional estación espacial
internacional hace ahora un año y en
materia de meteorología como les decía a
los analistas expertos y meteorólogos de
la nasa de la agencia espacial han
estado monitoreando las condiciones del
tiempo en las últimas horas y entonces
también he encontrado y recabar
información sobre estos chequeos y es
que hay tres chequeos críticos el último
se sucede tan sólo a una hora del
despegue gers en el que dicen ok o
cancelamos ha sido ok hemos recibido ese
aquella minutos del lanzamiento y desde
aquí estamos reportando ahora aclara
este sería el tercer lanzamiento de
astronautas desde suelo estadounidense
tras la alianza de la nasa con space ex
le pregunto qué se espera estos cuatro
astronautas que realicen en la estación
espacial internacional
bueno precisamente en rueda de prensa el
astronauta francés toma pesqué que es
ingeniero aeroespacial aeronáutico
también piloto comentó que esta vez
tendrán tareas divididas los cuatro van
a ser parte del proyecto y van a dividir
las tareas eso sí vamos a destacar algo
y es que es que va a ser el supervisor
de esta misión en la segunda mitad del
proyecto y un dato curioso ellos cuatro
van a tardar 10 horas en llegar hasta la
estación internacional y ahí van a
encontrarse con el crew 1 este es el
crew 2 el que está viajando en estos
momentos se van a encontrar con uno y
van a convivir 11 astronautas en esa
estación
pese a que ojo el número máximo fueron
fue de 13 astronautas el año pasado
allí van a estar explorando analizando
materiales que los científicos no tienen
acceso desde aquí desde la tierra y así
podrán darnos más información también
van a estar renovando y actualizando
cables nos contaban en una rueda de
prensa que tienen más de 20 años de
antigüedad clara gracias por toda esa
información de este lanzamiento
espectacular que pudimos observar en la
brugada de este viernes vamos ahora a
toulouse el sur de francia allí se
encuentra en la ciudad del espacio el
centro de la astronomía científica que
recibe unos 275 mil visitantes al año
está nuestra periodista natalia ruiz
natalia muy buenos días como se vivió
este lanzamiento desde el centro de
astronomía en francia que albergó a
varios astronautas para ver esta hazaña
del space acz
muy buenos días pues así es fue un
fenómeno momentos unos minutos muy
emocionantes aquí llenos de aplausos una
vez que el falcon 9 pues logró despegar
desde cabo cañaveral uo aplausos allí y
luego hubo más aplausos todavía cuando
ya logró su dragón entrar estar cuando
falcon 9 puso a cruz dragón ya en órbita
unos 200 kilómetros la distancia de la
tierra a unos 27.000 kilómetros por hora
en esa velocidad y cuando los cuerpos de
los astronautas pues eran sometidos a
una fuerza g de 14 es decir 4 veces el
peso del cuerpo en cada uno de ellos
ahora pues el criterium va hacia la
estación espacial internacional pero se
va a demorar prácticamente unas 24 horas
18 24 horas en llegar hasta allí y
hablamos aquí con el club de reyes
astronauta francesa de la agencia
europea y estuvo a bordo de la estación
espacial en el 2001 nos dijo cómo va a
desarrollarse estas estas horas antes de
la llegada a la plataforma espacial
los diez minutos de decolaje y puesta en
órbita son intensos de suma vigilancia y
luego tienen tiempo de relajarse un poco
en la cápsula
jibril a la estación en esta parte del
viaje que los llevará a la estación
espacial para estar en forma y llegar
bien a la estación donde se juzga cómo
podrán tomar una siesta una vez estén en
órbita y hayan hecho las comprobaciones
esto les permitirá adaptarse a la
microgravedad dijo white
bueno lo cierto es que durante todo este
tiempo pues dragon va a darle la vuelta
a la tierra 16 veces esto le va a
permitir a ganar un poco en velocidad
también en encenderán los motores unas
cuatro a cinco veces durante este
espacio de tiempo y bueno ya después
lograremos llegar a la estación espacial
internacional y que comience finalmente
esa misión de seis meses de club
2 hay que saber algo y es que como bien
lo decía la enviada especial a cabo
cañaveral pues van a estar todos estos
astronautas 11 astronautas a conviviendo
unos días y luego ya serán siete por
espacio de los próximos seis meses y le
preguntamos también al señor ay qué es
lo más difícil de estas misiones largas
y esto fue lo que nos contó cómo te
presentamos cuando la misión ya hay
momentos muy intensos tienen un programa
científico muy cargado un software son
cientos de científicos y de ingenieros
en tierra les han encomendado tareas
mantener esta estación que ya tiene 20
años en órbita y habrá que hacer salidas
extra
como para cambiar paneles solares que
proveen energía y hay que cambiarlos
porque ya tienen unos años
bueno y pues el club dragón finalmente
es casi como ir en taxi hasta la
estación espacial internacional porque
todo está automatizado y una vez logre
este acoplamiento se espera eso sea en
la mañana de este sábado hay que saber
como bien lo decían si es una misión muy
importante muy importante sobre todo
para para la agencia espacial europea
porque bueno estoy pisando un fuerte que
regresa digamos o que hace este este
asocio con a la nasa con jaxa igualmente
pero también porque es una misión a
clave para esta agencia sobre todo como
parte del programa artemisa que busca
poner de nuevo a los hombres al hombre
sobre la luna esto entre 2024 y 2025
natalia gracias por información ahora
dejamos a un lado el espacio y bajamos a
la tierra porque ayer se celebró el día
de nuestro planeta la fecha elegida por
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
para convocar una cumbre sobre el clima
con 40 líderes mundiales precisamente
eeuu y la unión europea se
comprometieron a reducir sus emisiones
de gases invernadero
la mitad para el 2030 y conseguir la
neutralidad de las emisiones es decir
emitir la misma cantidad de carbono que
el país puede absorber para el año 2050
unos compromisos que aceleran los
objetivos del acuerdo de parís vamos
hasta washington 10 y con nuestro
corresponsal cristóbal vázquez para que
nos cuente los detalles de lo que se
espera que suceda hoy en el segundo día
y último de esta cumbre del clima
cristóbal lo saludo muy buen día
sí buenos días las sesiones empezarán
hoy a las 8 de la mañana hora de
washington y se tratarán dos temas
específicos
el primero es cómo activar la innovación
climática en este punto se conversará
sobre la influencia de la tecnología
para lograr la neutralidad de carbono y
también pues cuáles son las
oportunidades para construir una nueva
industria del futuro el segundo tema que
se tratará será las oportunidades
económicas en la acción climática aquí
se piensa hacer un énfasis en cómo
generar empleo en esta acción climática
algunos de los participantes a resaltar
en este segundo día será por ejemplo el
primer ministro israelí benjamín
netanyahu el presidente de españa pedro
sánchez y estará también michael
bloomberg ex candidato presidencial
multimillonario ex alcalde nueva york
que ahora asume el rol de enviado
especial en la acción climática para el
gobierno de estados unidos también
estará bill gates que pues es fundador
de microsoft ya lo sabemos y también que
escribió recientemente el libro como
evitar un desastre climático finalmente
estará pintura que avanzará en la agenda
de el plan de infraestructura de eeuu
que incluye varias acciones contra el
cambio climático cristóbal gracias por
la información nosotros continuamos aquí
en el estudio colombiana cerró el jueves
con una nueva cifra récord de fallecidos
por el coi 19 430 personas muertas en un
día es el número de víctimas mortales
más alto desde el inicio de la pandemia
que ha llevado al país a cruzar el
umbral de los 70 mil fallecidos
colombia superó las 70 mil muertes por
kobe 19 tras registrar un récord fúnebre
el jueves
430 personas perdieron la vida en el
país la cifra más alta desde el inicio
de la pandemia
colombia se encuentra inmersa en plena
tercera ola y las autoridades han
endurecido las restricciones en las
principales ciudades como bogotá cali y
medellín donde la ocupación de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos se
acerca al 90%
los toques de queda nocturnos se han
extendido a nivel nacional igual que las
cuarentenas totales durante los fines de
semana
la alcaldesa de bogotá augura un futuro
difícil durante los próximos días es
posible que hoy cerremos a 90%
ocupaciones y hoy
y sigue creciendo y sigue creciendo
sobre todo en estas dos semanas que
vamos a pasar por un momento de verdad
muy crítico estamos literalmente entre
la vida y la muerte de la mano desde el
inicio de la semana las muertes diarias
por kobe 19 no han bajado de las 400 el
20 de abril también tuvo un récord de
fallecidos mientras el gobierno trata de
avanzar en su plan de vacunación se han
inoculado más de 41 millones de dosis
especialmente a adultos mayores y otros
grupos prioritarios aunque menos de un
millón y medio de personas están
inmunizadas con las dos dosis en un país
con más de 50 millones de habitantes
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo de france 24 continúan con
nosotros muy buen día para todos
[Música]
todas las semanas tenemos una